hey good humans jason from jubilee here
at the jubilee office i just want to
take a moment to say thank you to
the ridge wallet for sponsoring this
episode
i honestly just got this wallet and i
think it's incredible
i think it looks super dope really
really sleek
super thin and also really really
durable it's amazing and it has a full
lifetime
warranty
it can hold up to 12 cards which is a
big concern sometimes i have with
thin wallets and has space for your cash
as well
i highly recommend it i've loved
carrying it around they've got over 30
different options for colors
uh you can have carbon fiber burnt
titanium i honestly love it so much i
might get a second one just so i can
kind of switch out
the colorways there's also even a 45-day
guarantee
so if you get it and you don't love it
you can always send it back for a full
refund so there is no risk
if you use our code jubilee you actually
get 10 off make sure you check them out
and with father's day around the corner
this could be the perfect gift for your
father
or honestly yourself or your mother
anyone really
make sure you check out ridgewater thank
you again for the sponsorship and we
hope you enjoy this episode
i'm so i can't repeat ben i love what
you represent
i love it but the fact of the matter is
like your altruism doesn't
doesn't actually hit the the masses
large institutional investors have lost
tens of millions of dollars the
assumption that the reddit crowd were
idiots is incorrect
why do you think this is important
what's happening there's an enormous
sort of crowdsourced effort to uh
identify
forms of corruption in this case it's
not really sticking it to the man it's
ill-informed discussions that are being
had creating risk
this is not going to end well when it
ends and will end very badly for the
public
they shouldn't be just willy-nilly
distributing that to the four corners of
the wind because somebody at their
barbershop told them that they were
gonna make a million bucks off of
gamestop
i think there's an assumption there that
we aren't as
astute just because we don't have
whatever quote-unquote certification you
want to give someone
i'm always curious how people buy into
systems broadly especially systems like
wall street bets which is
so based in things like racism and
ableism but there's also
some people that are doing very
interesting deep dive financial
evaluations so to kind of put everyone
in one basket i feel like is a little
unfair
the surrounding message is so much more
important
than the money that i could be putting
in my pocket right now so
i'm still holding diamond hands on the
noise
[Music]
i started my career at goldman sachs
before moving to an alts firm
in la how's it going everyone i'm danny
i worked in
finance i'm also been an entrepreneur
for the past 10 years
my name is mike i am the cso of a cpg
startup
hey guys my name is from nick i'm a
registered investment advisor and real
estate broker
hey guys my name is zach i'm in the
medical device sales space
and i also host a podcast called diy
wealth my name is ben
i'm the proud owner of several shares of
gamestop
and i'm hodling until the squeeze is
closed
i have invested in meme stock come
forward if you agree
i it might be a little obvious why we
invested in the meme stock but i
definitely want to hear why you did yeah
i think if you think about
meme in a different way right so like
i've invested in stocks that were like
memes on my desk
yeah like i know this isn't going
anywhere like this is kind of a joke
i own some like random bdc companies
that like i would consider like
this is like a joke a meme stock nothing
quite to this level
things do trade on social sentiment now
if you got a couple
a couple bucks that you're willing to go
broke on and watch it drive all the way
down to zero
why not you know throw throw the dice on
a couple of these where you know elon
musk says something and they just launch
i think that's like something that i
have qualms with in the market as a
like as a whole right now like if you're
treating a little bit of your portfolio
like that now even if you have the
overall sentiment like market goes up
like stocks go burr you have to still be
able to have that mindset of like this
theoretically like
worst case scenario could go to zero as
far as mean stops
meme stocks go i'm drawn to
nailing naked short sellers that's my
whole agenda here
so sticking to the man um i don't it's
just insane to me that for four decades
the sec
has failed to get control of naked short
selling as an illegal practice
so the only meme stocks i'm interested
in in buying are the
uh short squeeze stocks like gamestop
and amc so yours is like a spike in my
online stop right now it's a spite
investment absolutely
one of the things that that ben said
that kind of piqued my interest is the
idea that you're you're
doing this to stick it to the man i love
the sentiment uh i love
what you want to accomplish but the
thing that i kind of would push back
with is the fact that
the man is also winning i agree with you
that there's going to be
big guy firms that profit off of the
gamestop uh
phenomenon but i suppose as long as
at least one naked short seller gets
their comeuppance
what's that i feel like at the end of
the day too on the forum
like there were individuals that were
pulling out and saying because of this
money that came into my world
i was able to pay for cancer treatment
for my mother and things like that
but what about the people who are dying
of like crazy losses i feel like
for every me millionaire that wall
street bets makes i'm not talking about
even millionaires though just
but it's non-verified non-backed up
information there's so i mean granted
reddit has their thumbs up platform and
the anonymity that they provide their
users does provide a level of access and
freedom
but you're still receiving information
that has not been verified that doesn't
necessarily want the analytics to back
it up so why does webmd exist then
we're not going to a doctor you're not
verifying anything right now but you're
going and doing your own due diligence
on why you might be sick or how you're
feeling
of course but you're doing it on actual
factual information diseases
anatomy physiology and you're not doing
it based upon an artificially inflated
market that can be influenced by so many
different realms
right but one of the things is with the
reddit forum to me it's just theory
crafting it's just people theorycrafting
their own due diligence and putting
their opinion behind it if someone takes
that seriously and executes against it
the risk is on them to do that in this
space here i agree with you
but do you think your average consumer
that's out there that is investing
based upon this movement is doing that
same due diligence that has that same
information absolutely not but
what at what point is it fair for me to
be
hindered on my acquiring of knowledge
because someone else is choosing to be
stupid careless and ignorant
wall street bets is a movement
as is sort of my agenda here um i think
wall street bets is an incredible
movement for raising
awareness about a litany of unfair
practices at the highest levels of uh
the stock market number one this whole
gamestop thing started because of an
illegal practice called naked short
selling
i would say it's also a movement of uh
crowdsourcing this enormous amount of
investment knowledge and distributing it
to an enormous pool of there's 10
million subscribers now
do you think the 10 million actually get
that knowledge
uh no not all of them but i don't think
one percent of them do that that's kind
of my whole thing oh
like i i'm so i can't repeat ben i love
what you represent i love it but the
fact of the matter is like your altruism
doesn't
doesn't actually hit the the masses
i believe wall street bets is a movement
kind of like nazism and communism and
all these other bad news
i think it's a terrible movie nazism
we had more of a positive connotation
with the movement you drug it all the
way over to
another let me be completely canned i
was being facetious i don't think it's
that bad
i don't think it's that bad i i'm not
okay with the fact that the main losers
aren't the guys you're trying to like
screw out of this like terrible terrible
unknown melvin capital lost what but
they immediately got bailed out by
citadel
and how many more giant conglomerate
firms made
bazillions of dollars while my good
friends lost a thousand bucks here ten
thousand dollars this year i don't want
people like like you guys
so like us losing money so i guess on a
scale though so when you have this forum
where people go around and pitch around
decent ideas whether great due diligence
or
absolutely none was done and then you
have you you remember a couple years ago
wells fargo creating the fake bake
accounts
like turbo oh right yeah why why is
there so much laser focus on
accountability on this
you know ragtag crew for drums and
absolutely nothing changed on the wells
fargo i'm there with you
what's happening here is we're
conflating two different things
reddit is a forum and a platform that's
aggregating sentiment
it is not one thing like a hedge fund
with one goal is to make money off some
niche is one thing
reddit is just a collection of lots of
different sentiments
now is that a movement in itself no has
it created byproducts
that are exposing things that are maybe
not in the investors interest i would
say yes and then another thing is
robinhood like they're one of the the
genius of robin hood has been they've
gamified investing
and it's played into a narrative that
isn't true which people already have an
inclination to interpret investing as
gambling and that's not what investing
is about right right
you know i 100 agree with you there but
if you look at what's going on
the amount of risk that we have created
just by these movements and allowing
this type of influence
to be made within our financial space we
don't even understand the repercussions
of that but at the end of the day i
think
the underlying thing is earnings per
share revenue
how much money you can make and come
hell or high water
that's the game of the capitalistic free
market systems but if it
if it leads to the downfall and
bankruptcy of companies
or institutional investors and companies
falling out going into bankruptcy what
type of instability does that create
within not only our local economic
environment
but on a global scale are you actually
concerned that could happen and that
would be catastrophic for
the average american no not for the
average american but i think the average
american who is taking
their stimulus package and investing it
into game stop and realistically doesn't
have
the funds to be genuinely investing and
they need to be building those capital
assets
i think that's more what's at risk in
this movement and essentially what the
problem is and the economic fallout
do you think that's like a you question
like how much money was donated to the
foster gorilla fund do you know like
approximately
oh i mean uh not to like put you on the
spot because you're sure i believe
it was in the millions not right like
thousands like i would even argue like
that donation alone like as someone who
doesn't really like wall street bets as
a space
i would even argue like that alone was a
movement of itself
not like a big like not like oh like
occupy wall street not black lives
matter nothing like that but like
the fact is that people did turn around
and were like hey like we said this is
something that we're doing for good and
like here's a direct impact
the racial undertones and like ableism i
think is a little iffy
and like wall street beds pioneering
gorillas as
their mascot i think leads to a lot of
icky moments
um as someone who left wall street
because someone black was called a
gorilla
i think it's a lot of fun wow full
circle moment
but like i think even that you can be
like yeah like there's underlying
we want to do good as a movement
all investors should have access to the
same type of tools
and resources
i wish i had the same information as
those congress people
who went and sold all their stocks
right before trump announced the
pandemic to the public
politics political structure i mean
level of information based upon national
security
kind of hard to exchange when you're
working within a government agency if
they made those moves we can talk about
the ethics of that
later the same information that your
your trading houses had was the same
information that was out there to the
individual investor at that time
um possibly i don't think i disagree
with that
i wholeheartedly believe in reality we
live in a plutocracy right now
do you know what a plutocracy i do so um
the government is controlled for
and manipulated and used for by the
wealthy
so i think there is a level of green
privilege and plutocracy and with having
lots of money and power there is certain
information that's streamlined
to people in higher positions than your
average person therefore
all of the tools aren't given being
given
to everyone equally on a playing field
when it comes to what the institutional
houses realistically have when it comes
to information the analytics
and the actual statistics that are out
there and available
they are available to the general public
well you say that but then enron would
literally make calls to wall street and
tell them to do blackouts in california
and they would manipulate the stock
price and then they would short it and
buy it when it would dump it when it
would tank and go up how can you sit
there and go
that's an equal level of information
being given to everybody
is that is that information but is that
information or ethics it's essentially
the same thing when you go to the doctor
okay everything that he knows is
accessible online to you you can
research it you can webmd it you can
actually buy the same medical books that
he was there
correct okay at the end of the day it's
a matter of whether you're going to go
in there and do the work
but at the end of the day it also
matters about the timeline if i take the
time to do the due diligence even though
he has all that information
and it's the difference between getting
the proper cancer treatment two weeks
down the road or immediately
that's vital information that that
person needed to know in order to get
the treatment exactly
so you're highlighting that a subject
matter expert should realistically have
more access to the information in a more
time efficient manner than a layman
well it's not time efficient they just
take the time to do it i see that i see
what how your
i see how you're positioning that but at
the end of the day if you're someone
that has
enough knowledge to utilize the
information just as efficiently
why do i have to wait because you have a
certification or because you have a
doctorate or because you have higher
education
for the same reason you can't fly a
plane you're not qualified you didn't do
the work you're not there
regardless would you agree there's very
terrible pilots and there's very good
pilots
of course there are but they're all
qualified they're all certified and
they've all done the work to get there
as per usual i have so much to say i was
very sad i could
feel you wrong i could feel you over
there thank you
people do have equal access to
information and like i'm not against
equitable information i actually think
that's like where i did agree
i don't agree that everyone should have
the same tools why not same um as
someone who's like traded on a lot of
those platforms
are like i don't think the average
investor like needs to be making million
dollar pars deals
and like if that platform is free like
people can't do that
there's a degree of responsibility that
we being a little bit more informed
having more insight into the process
should take
to protect our fellow man who doesn't
have that
same level of information that same
level of knowledge because my concern is
that
the information that's being pushed is
barbershop information
right and we're pushing that as if it
were legitimate verified
valuable information in some cases it's
extremely well thought out research
in some cases sure sure absolutely but
it's just dangerous
i know people personally like my family
has lost quite a bit of money
because of barbershop information if if
our approach is let's just deregulate
everything not care
about who gets hurt then a lot of people
who don't have the same privilege of
information and knowledge
aren't going to approach it properly and
ethically or intelligently
and so the to the flip side of your coin
i come from a very fragmented familial
situation
my my mother and my father they'll
probably have to work until they die
because they didn't fundamentally
understand financial concepts
to leverage themselves into a situation
where they reach
early retirement or financial freedom or
whatever but
because there has been a huge amount of
information made available to me
and i have actively made those choices
whether i find it through wall street
bets or wherever else
i've put myself in a very empowered
position in order to achieve
the end goal of an earlier retirement or
financial freedom
we're not looking to take away the
opportunity at all we're looking to just
make sure people know what they're
getting into
and i know like it seems like well you
know it's it's their fault if they if
they get involved and they're not
doing it correctly but we have
precautions all throughout society
whether it's
i mean gun laws aren't exactly the best
example but like driver's licenses
you know like people buy cigarettes in
the days suicides still happen
you know and gun violence still happen
but we still have precautions
we have tools to protect those people
but at the end of the day can you go
represent yourself when you purchase
your home
do you have to have a real estate agent
no no no you don't have so
why are we putting such a focus and
emphasis on you
have to be this professional to use xyz
but like i've never heard of someone
like representing themselves in court
never being like
that is a great plan right and that's a
good example i
i statistically would i represent myself
in court no but do i have the option to
yes well like you have the opportunity
you have the option to be in these
systems like we're not saying that
that's not true
but like there is things that come with
being licensed and being a professional
in a space
shorting stocks is a legitimate and fair
practice
guys look at us
well i was trying to think of an example
where it would be considered not
right a fair practice it's no different
than going out into nature and watching
something that's sick and dying get
eaten by lions like
that's just part of the process but i
think naked short selling was
um has been restricted since like 2014
or something
like so that's kind of out of the market
like if you're gonna call it naked
shorts i think if you call a lot of
other like wall street practices and i
think a lot of these things are like
good yes like you're absolutely not
wrong
as you should be doing but like i think
to be like it's just naked shorts
we've identified like the issue like
that's the heart like yeah
i was like a lot of the outrage
was generated by this feeling that
predatory short sellers
were trying to put gamestop out of
business prior to
the the time when it would naturally die
when predatory short sellers
engage in naked short selling to put a
company out of business there's nothing
natural
like a lion uh killing a deer about that
that is but they're not going after
companies like amazon right like they're
going after companies
that clearly the fundamentals are
looking a little sh game stopping
games brick and mortar retail video game
seller people on reddit
see uh the future of gamestop
very much as a new company as a company
with a new
vision um that will be modeled after
chewie
and will be more uh internet based and
less brick and mortar based
why i just don't think that that many
people have enough
understanding even to be like doing this
remotely responsibly
the damage done to hedge funds by wall
street vets
was deserved
the uh you know there have been a lot of
celebrities who have chimed in
on uh the gamestop and amc short
squeezes
and one of them uh struck a chord with
me which was
uh one of the shark tank guys kevin
o'leary he
said if you're stupid enough to short a
stock
over a hundred percent then you deserve
whatever happens to you
i am delighted to see them uh pay
financially for um
[Music]
for playing dirty in the most important
game in the universe which is
uh the game of uh american capitalism
your call i'll take the phone fair
enough it's time to keep changing it up
i started immediately like identifying
with it and i haven't been able to
properly articulate
why yet but initially in my gut i heard
the word deserved
i don't agree with that word that's why
i didn't come to the table
i also tried to ask myself did they
deserve that's like saying
does any investor deserve the risk
they're taking and i think a lot of
people get behind the initial statement
that was said was because this is very
much turned into a david and goliath
narrative
but that's that's the thing it's a
narrative correct we say like deserve
not deserve but the question is what
damage
wait so that was my like that was the
word that i'm hung up on it's like what
damage do we really think happened to
hedge funds
it's a symbolism as look you guys all
had this cushy job you had billions you
were managing now you don't some of you
are out do you really think there was a
lot of squirming
when you look at the people that were
really vested in that company do you
think they really took the losses that
you think they did
or do you think they're writing that
golden parachute laughing at the
at the narrative that's going out
there's other repercussions besides
just the losses on amc and gamestop
which would be
an enormous amount of public pressure on
the sec to enforce the rules that they
already have
that have been poorly enforced that is
potentially a repercussion that will
affect
the day-to-day lives of hedge funds now
you're speaking my language because when
you talk about it like
we've already won the war that's when
i'm like first of all i'm kind of on
your side
and moreover when we're like oh we made
them square and we were winning here
i'm like no you haven't even you haven't
even started the game
i i think that there's about 10 million
redditors who are gonna hang on to this
forever and a lot of us are motivated by
the grudge we still feel
from the lack of justice during the 08
fiasco let's call it yeah one guy went
to jail
after the collusion that led to
the mortgage-backed security crisis it's
hard to
to pin the the idea that um
people involved in the mortgage-backed
security crisis were aware that that
what they were doing at every point
along the way
was going to lead to a global financial
crisis and deaths of poverty
but if you could prove that i would say
they would be
guilty of mass murder i don't think
people care but essentially how many
people still care about that issue today
what wall street vets did the exposures
and the blind spots in our financial
system
in a whole there are a few of course
what you have to do is
let's take a few what we have to do is
you have to understand what those are
and you have to mobilize and you have to
create a situation where
there's actual change on the books if
you just hold
if you just hold gamestop it's not going
to change anything you gotta
this is this was an illustration of some
of the blind spots and it has to
mobilize into a more social event
in terms of representatives and leaders
that say you know what there are some
things that the financial institutions
have a blind spot on and we have to do
some reforms you definitely have the
communication tool and the movement
passion to do so but realistically is
there's a staying power
i guarantee you that i personally have
the power to hold a grudge for the rest
of my life
i respect that i feel that i'm right i
feel that
and i believe there's about 10 million
redditors who
equally are going to hold this grudge
maybe not forever
i think you're too smart i think you're
too smart and too engaged
like i think that's the issue you're
gonna have to take you're gonna have to
take that
grudge and mobilize it into actual
social change
and that comes from leadership right and
that comes from new elected officials so
you gotta
you gotta you gotta crosswalk that into
actual stuff
[Music]
do
you